المتبعه ينضم الي من اسطنبول لمراسل
الجزيره عمر الحاج مرحبا عمر اذا انقضت
ساعتان الاولىان من عمر هذه الانتخابات في
جولتها الثانيه الاقبال في اسطنبول التي
كثيرا ما توصف بالخزان الانتخابي
نعم محمد استطيع القول ان الاقبال كثيف
جدا هنا في مدينه اسطنبول خلال هاتين
الساعتين كان لنا فرصه ان نتجول في
مراكز مختلفه ووسط المدينه في احيائها
المتوسطه غازي عثمان باشا وانا الان في
اقصى الغرب في حي بيليق دوزو بسرعه زميل
الخير سياريكم كثافه الاقبال هنا في هذا
المركز الذي سيصوت به بعد قليل بالمناسبه
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول الكبرى اقرب امام اولو
عن حزب الشعب الجمهوري والمرشح لمنصب نائب
الرئيس في حاله فوزي منافسه كمال
كما كنت اذكر حقيقه الاقبال كثيف جدا في
مختلف المراكز التي زرناها سوريناصر كما
ذكرتم في الخبر كان يتحدث عن اختلاف في
هذه الانتخابات في هذه الجوله بالتحديد
اشار الى ان هذه الانتخابات شاهدت احداثا
اقل من
الجولات السابقه او الاستحقاقات السابقه
السابقه وهي يقول اتمنى ان مر هذه
الانتخابات بسلام كما ذكرت اكرم مولى هو
المسؤول الوحيد ربما من حزب الشعب
الجمهوري الذي سيصوت في هذه المدرسه ثم
سينتقل سريعا الى انقره لمتابعه سير
العمليه الانتخابيه من المنتظر ايضا ان
يصوت الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في كما
العاده في في مركز اعتاد على التصويت عليه
خلال السنوات السابقه في حي سكودار في
الجانب
الاسيوي من مدينه اسطنبول وباختصار حقيقه
هناك اقبال كبير في مختلفي المراكز هنا في
هذه المدينه